ed miliband do you think Britain is full
in terms of immigration yes I wouldn't
describe it that way no I think we've
got very high levels of migration I
think that we do need to try and get
those levels of migration down
particularly through high now yeah but
I'm tell you one thing very important
I'm not going to make you I'm not gonna
make a false promise on this because the
David Cameron did make that comment on
the minds of thousands now you've got
form on false promises on immigration
haven't you me personally your
government yeah we've got a part we got
it wrong you got it completely you got
it wrong yeah it would your fingers were
farcical yeah they were wrong yeah let
me take two things about your important
okay just make me about immigrations you
asked me a question let me answer it
look I think that we benefit from our
diversity immigrants over the years have
made a big contribution to our country
but we do need proper controls let me
just say this Jeremy
we a Labour government would say that if
people come here they can't get benefits
for the first two years and we will do
something else
I'm not talking about benefits are
you're talking about immigration I'm
talking about numbers right and let me
tell you the way we will sitting we've
got to a figure of 17 million in 10 or
15 years population this country is that
acceptable I'm not going to get into
your hypotheticals let me say I think we
can get low skilled migration down so
I'm not going to stop making about
number eight no I'm not saying that 75
million I'm 80 million come on 95
million 100 million let me say what I'm
gonna do
let me say what I'm gonna do because
that's what matters rather than
speculating about figures I want to get
low skilled migration down and I think
the controls we're talking about not
just on benefits but on stopping the
undercutting of wages because people
have being brought into the country to
undermine the minimum wage and various
other things I think they will help to
get lower migration down but if what
you're saying to me is would it be
better for our country for example
withdrawal from the European Union I've
mentioned the year what do you mean no
no I'll tell you why I'm saying making
up a question to yourself I'm not I'm
not acting as a big choice at this
election Jeremy there is a choice of
this election I believe that we can
bring in controls on migration sensible
controls but I'm not going to make false
promises or put forward full solutions
either
I'm just asking you if you think there's
any natural limit to the population in
this country and I'm not going to get
drawn into a speculation about a number
you don't think there is a natural limit
of course there are limits but the
limits are expressive leaving them to
yourself the limits are expressed in the
decisions you take year by year and I've
explained some of the decisions that
will make